jetzt denn jetzt sehen wir in berlin
kommen die bundeskanzlerin und die
vorsitzenden der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und er hat
es noch an berichten jetzt die
bundeskanzlerin
der regierende bürgermeister und der
ministerpräsident von bayern ja meine
damen und herren wir haben ausführlich
und intensiv beraten
sie wissen dass wir am 28 oktober 2020
er weitreichende beschränkungen in
teilen des öffentlichen lebens
beschlossen hatten und deren
geltungsdauer auch auf ende november
gelegt haben das heißt heute war es eine
zwischenbilanz und in dieser
zwischenbilanz wollten wir schauen was
wir verändern müssen wo wir stehen und
welche empfehlungen wir geben wir haben
gemeinsam festgestellt dass durch die
oktober beschlüsse und auch die tage
vielleicht schon zuvor eine trendumkehr
noch nicht erreicht ist aber wir die
dynamik der neuinfektionen brechen
konnten wir haben in den letzten tagen
eine konstante infektionszahlen gesehen
aber wir sind von der inzidenz von 50
pro 100000 in sieben tagen bei denen wir
dann das infektionsgeschehen für die
gesundheitsämter wieder für
nachvollziehbar halten ein großes stück
entfernt
wir möchten trotzdem sagen dass wir der
bevölkerung sehr danken dass wir diesen
schritt schon mal erreichen konnten wir
waren ja in einem starken exponentiellen
wachstum
als wir diese beschränkungen beschlossen
haben und auch darum bitten und die
menschen auffordern dies weiter so
einzuhalten denn die kontakt
beschränkungen sind das erfolgsrezept
und wir brauchen mehr davon wir müssen
noch stärker reduzieren damit wir auch
unsere ziele erreichen wir waren uns
einig dass wir heute noch nicht
abschließend sagen können was die
entwicklung der infektionszahlen für
ende nur werden
bedeutet deshalb wird es eine nächste
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit der
bundesregierung und der bundeskanzlerin
geben
am 25 november wo wir dann nicht nur
darüber entscheiden wollen wie es nach
dem 30
november weitergeht sondern wo wir auch
einen ausgegeben wollen bis zum beginn
des neuen jahres und die zeit der
wintermonate insgesamt damit ein stück
berechenbarkeit soweit man das kann in
die gesamte kroner pandemie situation
kommt diese berechenbarkeit wird von uns
angestrebt sie ist nie hundertprozentig
vorauszusagen aber wir wollen ein stück
planbarkeit so weit wie möglich geben
auch über die zeit von weihnachten und
den jahreswechsel hinweg darstellen sich
eine vielzahl von großen problemen
dass wir haben in dem beschluss noch
einmal hergeleitet und das entspricht
auch dem was jetzt im deutschen
bundestag und dem bundesrat
verabschiedeten opfer abschied wird im
dritten bevölkerungsschutz gesetz wie
die philosophie dessen ist was wir tun
immer angedockt an die infektionszahlen
und an die inzidenz aber natürlich auch
andere indikatoren in betracht ziehen
sie wissen der erwert spielt eine große
rolle
die verdopplung zeit spielt eine große
rolle wir waren uns aber einig dass die
belegung der intensivbetten ein städte
indikator ist der bei dem man das
infektionsgeschehen dann nicht mehr
stoppen kann und deshalb müssen wir
vorher handeln und diese ganze
philosophie die sich auch im paragrafen
28a des dritten bevölkerungsschutz
gesetzes widerspiegelt ist hier in
diesem beschluss noch einmal dargestellt
wir haben uns dann zu verschiedenen
themen geäußert man muss wissen die
bundesländer waren in ihrer
überwiegenden mehrheit der meinung sie
wollten jetzt quasi eine woche vor der
nächsten konferenz bei der es mit
sicherheit rechtsänderungen gibt keine
zwischen rechtsänderungen machen
darüber gab es
durchaus auch ein bisschen
unterschiedliche vorstellung ich hätte
mir auch vorstellen können dass wir im
bereich der kontakte heute schon
beschlüsse gefasst hätten die dann auch
rechtlich umgesetzt werden weil man ein
paar tage mehr zeit gehabt hat aber das
ist in der mehrheit der bundesländer
wenn man das in einem packen dann
nochmal machen
im anschluss an den nächsten mittwoch
aber wir haben deutlich noch einmal
gemacht worum es geht und damit die
bevölkerung aufgefordert bestimmte
regeln einzuhalten da geht es einmal
darum dass wir im zusammenhang mit mit
den atemwegserkrankungen die nicht
corona sind in diesem winter in der
pandemie besondere vorsichtsmaßnahmen
gelten lassen müssen das
robert-koch-institut hat hierzu
vorschläge gemacht und die heißen dass
wenn man die symptome hat dass man dann
sozusagen seinen arzt konsultiert sich
sofort nach hause begibt und bis zum
ablegen dieser symptome dann auch zu
hause bleibt wenn das ärztlich empfohlen
wird warum sagen wir dass es gibt in den
wintermonaten pro woche gab es ob das in
diesem winter so sein wird war ja alle
maske tragen es kann auch weniger sein
gab es sehr sehr viele
es liegt im millionenbereich von
erkältungssymptomen erkältungssymptomen
versehenen menschen die sozusagen in
ihren symptomatik nicht von corona zu
unterscheiden sind und deshalb ist mir
hier vorsicht walten lassen damit nicht
menschen mit symptomen die vielleicht
doch eine krone erkrankung bedeuten dann
andere menschen infizieren
es wird dann vom arzt festgelegt ob eine
testung geboten ist oder nicht ich
glaube das ist wichtig wir sagen
ansonsten und führen dass dann auch noch
mal etwas im detail aus dass auf alle
nicht erforderlichen kontakte zu
verzichten ist jeder kontakt der nicht
stattfindet ist gut für die bekämpfung
der ferne
das heißt das absolut nötige minimum an
kontakten ist zu gewährleisten und
deshalb sorgen wir noch einmal deutlich
auf private feiern ist gänzlich zu
verzichten
private zusammenkünfte mit freunden
verwandten und bekannten sollen auf
einen festen also immer den gleichen
weiteren hausstand beschränkt werden
und das schließt auch kinder und
jugendliche in den familien ein auf
freizeit bezogene aktivitäten und
besucher in bereichen mit
publikumsverkehr sowie nicht notwendige
private reisen und touristische
tagestouren muss verzichtet werden das
wiederholen und bekräftigen wir nochmal
es will sollte man soll nicht notwendige
aufenthalt in geschlossenen räumen mit
publikumsverkehr oder nicht notwendige
fahrten mit öffentlichen
beförderungsmittel vermeiden und dass
besucher bei älteren und wollen arabien
personen nur dann unternommen werden
sollen wenn die menschen wirklich
symptomfrei sind und sich in den tagen
davor keinem besonderen risiko
ausgesetzt haben
wir haben dann noch mal unsere hotspot
strategie bekräftigt denn wir haben in
deutschland ein sehr unterschiedliches
infektionsgeschehen wir haben länder wie
mecklenburg vorpommern schleswig
holstein sachsen anhalt da ist das
infektionsgeschehen in den vergangenen
tagen schon deutlich zurück gegangen und
wir haben andere länder in denen das
infektionsgeschehen noch sehr viel höher
ist
deshalb sind die maßnahmen die wir alle
ergriffen haben im falle von hot spots
häufig nicht ausreichend das heißt hier
muss man mehr machen und das wird auch
ausdrücklich gewünscht denn wir haben
nichts davon wenn in einigen ländern
nachher den zins incidents wieder bei 20
ist und in anderen ländern ist die nach
wie vor deutlich über 50 und unser ziel
ist dass wir unter die 50 auch wirklich
wieder kommen
wir haben uns größer zu der frage von
schulen und betreuungseinrichtungen wir
danken erst einmal all denen die unseren
politischen grundsatz wir wollen schulen
kitas aufhalten wir wollen dass schule
und kindergarten und kita stattfindet
die diesen grundsatz auch das
funktionieren geben also alle die im
schulwesen arbeiten den kindergarten
kinder gern
danken wir für alles was sie leisten und
wir wissen auch dass die länder sich
täglich mit dem funktionieren von kitas
kindergärten und schulen beschäftigen
wir haben neue empfehlungen der
leopoldina bekommen die aus meiner sicht
durchaus ernst zu nehmen sind und es ist
heute darüber gesprochen worden dass die
länder sich vor diesem hintergrund noch
einmal mit der frage beschäftigen was
kann man auch gerade in hotspots tun um
das infektionsgeschehen zu reduzieren im
lichte dieser erkenntnisse wir sind dann
auf das thema internet eingegangen die
haben wir heute wieder eine sehr
erfolgreiche nachricht oder eine gute
nachricht bekommen für einen zweiten
impfstoff von der firma moderner das ist
nebenbei und tag ein sehr gutes zeichen
und deshalb müssen die logistischen
vorbereitungen für in zentren jetzt
zwischen bund und ländern gut
abgesprochen werden damit wir nachher
wenn wir impfstoff haben zum fall impfen
wir wissen nicht ganz genau wann es
anfangen kann aber es kann auch recht
bald sein
dann wollen wir auch wirklich
handlungsfähig seien sie haben darüber
geredet wie kann der grüne ramelow
gruppen noch besser schützen und der
bund hat sich entschlossen dass wir
menschen die zu einer solchen gruppe
gehören das muss im detail noch
ausgearbeitet werden durch das
gesundheitsministerium dass wir menschen
15 fsp zwei masken das sind also eine
pro winter mit einer eine pro woche
mit einer wirklich guten anleitung auch
widrigen genutzt werden können
zur verfügung stellen wollen bei einer
kleinen eigenbeteiligung weil wir wissen
dass diese masken sehr doch finanz
wirksam sind sie sind relativ teuer
gemessenen alltags masken und deshalb
wollen wir jeden in der in die lage
versetzen wenn er zu einer variablen
gruppe gehört dass man sich das auch
wirklich zulegen kann und wir werden
dazu die ratschläge des gemeinsamen
bundesausschusses der so eine
entscheidung am besten treffen kann auch
sachgerecht treffen kann
grundlage machen das soll ab dezember
losgehen es gibt dazu eine
verordnungsermächtigung für den
bundesgesundheitsminister im
infektionsschutzgesetz wir haben eine
lösung gefunden für die unterstützung
der krankenhäuser bei denen mehr und
mehr profit 19 patienten sind und so wie
wir dann sicherstellen können dass
bestimmte operationen zurückgestellt
werden dass die krankenhäuser dadurch
aber keine finanziellen nachteile
erleiden
wir wollen dass etwas besser steuern als
das im frühjahr war da war es eine sehr
teure sehr pauschale regelung aber ich
glaube wir haben jetzt eine gute
gefunden wir sagen etwas zur
digitalisierung der gesundheitsämter wo
es jetzt auch vorangeht und unterstützen
doch einmal deutlich die korona waren
app alles im halben für eine
zwischenbilanz ein guter beschluss und
ich glaube wir werden dann sehr intensiv
die neue mpk vorbereiten müssen wo es
darum sehr viel weitergehende und länger
dauernde beschlüsse geht immer ausgehend
von dem ziel dass wir wieder den zugriff
für die kontakt nachverfolgung bekommen
müssen das heißt mindestens 50 pro
100000 fälle in sieben tagen erreichen
müssen das ist noch eine ganz schöne
wegstrecke aber die gute nachricht ist
wir haben erstmal das exponentielle
wachstum gestoppt und das erfolgt uns
alle
ja ich glaube dass wir heute eine
wichtige konferenz und ein wichtiger tag
der bestandsaufnahme und er hat gezeigt
dass wir gemeinsam bund wie länder
dran sind an den ganzen themen das
infektionsgeschehen ist und dass wir uns
nach wie vor permanent und sehr eng
abstimmen und gemeinsame ziele verfolgen
und insofern war es wichtig dass wir
heute auch noch mal klar festhalten
konnten was wir gemeinsam erreicht haben
sowie die bundeskanzlerin kanzlerin ist
eben daraus geführt hat wir haben die
infektions dynamik verlangsamen können
aber wir haben insofern muss man das
immer klar sagen viel erreicht aber noch
längst nicht genug sondern die situation
ist weiter besorgniserregend und das
eint uns auch dass wir in dieser
hinsicht die nächste konferenz sehr gut
vorbereiten wollen und sehr gut
vorbereiten werden weil dann
gegebenenfalls im beschlüsse anstehen
die auch langfristig eine perspektive
und eine planungssicherheit bieten
sollen für den dezember für den januar
wir haben das heute konkret festgehalten
dass das auch im rahmen eines
langfristigen konzepts eines
gesamtkonzepts dann auch formuliert
werden soll wie wir über diese
sicherlich nicht einfachen wintermonate
die jetzt vor uns liegen kommen werden
ich will auch für mich noch mal klar
sagen der vergangenen woche habe ich mir
mit olaf scholz zusammen ja in der
charité ein beet auch der lage direkt
machen können
und tatsächlich ist das bedrückt und wir
haben jetzt in berlin erstmals 1000
corona patienten die gleichzeitig
behandelt werden in den berliner
krankenhäusern und dass es irgendetwas
was man nicht wegdiskutieren kann
sondern was schlichtweg die neutrale
faktenbasis ist für das was jetzt eben
von uns auch zu bewältigen ist die
infektionszahlen haben ganz konkrete
auswirkungen in der intensivmedizin und
insofern sind wir nach wie vor in einer
situation die wir bewältigen können
medizinisch in unseren kliniken aber es
wird schwieriger und genau diese
situation müssen wir jetzt für die
nächsten wochen und monate entschärfen
damit werden wir uns wie gesagt mit den
maßnahmen die auch schon genannt wurden
und insbesondere auch was die kontakt
möglich
kiten anbelangt damit werden wir uns in
der nächsten konferenz auseinandersetzen
ich möchte zwei dinge noch mal ganz
besonders betonen die uns ein glaube ich
auch sehr am herzen liegen das eine ist
die situation in den schulen
es ist sehr sehr viel erreicht worden ja
auch durch die politischen beschlüsse
durch bund und länder aber vor allen
dingen von den handelnden vor ort wir
sehen natürlich auch david das
infektionsgeschehen sich entwickelt aber
man muss es einordnen wir hatten am 12
november hatten wir deutschlandweit 100
und sechs schulen die geschlossen waren
das hört sich dramatisch an 100 schulen
es bewegt sich aber im unteren
promillebereich aller schulen die wir
bundesweit haben und das gleiche es
daneben auch der fall umgerechnet auf
die infizierten schülerinnen und schüler
noch einmal nichts schönzureden wir
müssen uns auch da die infektions
dynamik genauer ansehen aber sie ist
eben auch differenziert zu betrachten
je jünger die kinder sind das so weniger
infektionsgeschehen sehen wir vor allen
dingen des slowenen jahr
krankheitsverläufe sehen wir bei den
älteren schülern die dann er auch ins
erwachsenenalter kommen sieht das schon
wieder ganz anders aus wir werden uns
also mit sicherheit ganz besonders auch
in der nächsten konferenz dieser
situation widmen und werden sehen wie
wir einerseits die schülerinnen und
schüler aber auch die lehrerinnen und
lehrer schützen können was wir da auch
an zusätzliche maßnahmen anbieten können
von entsprechenden masken und schutz
verabredung bis hin zu testverfahren die
gegebenenfalls eingesetzt werden können
weil es das wird mit sicherheit eine
rolle spielen abschließend von meiner
seite ist das ganze thema
digitalisierung
die bundeskanzlerin hat eben schon auf
die app auch hingewiesen und noch einmal
ich weiß es gibt viel kritik auch an
dieser app aber die wird von sehr vielen
menschen genutzt und immer besser
genutzt und sie ist ein wichtiger
baustein
nicht mehr und nicht weniger ein
wichtiger baustein um zu sensibilisieren
und warm und sie wird weiter entwickelt
sie wird jetzt in den nächsten wochen
mit drei zusätzlichen funktionen auch
freigeschaltet und wir haben heute das
thema schon angesprochen was wir nächste
woche
auch noch einmal aufgreifen wollen ob
wir nicht weitere funktionen und
vernetzungsmöglichkeiten anbieten können
ob wir nicht den betroffenen auch wenn
sie sich zum beispiel haben testen
lassen ermöglichen wollen dass sie
gleich eine funktion freischalten können
wo ihre daten auch weitergegeben werden
für weitere kontakt nachverfolgung und
alle fragen die dann mit einem positiven
testergebnis zusammenhängen also auch
hier gibt es eine große offenheit sowohl
auf bundes seite wie auf seiten der
länder ein immer besseres angebot für
die bürgerinnen und bürger machen zu
können auch um damit immer mehr schutz
und immer mehr sicherheit zu ermöglichen
sind zwei punkte die aber mit sicherheit
in der nächsten konferenz eine rolle
spielen werden ja meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren es war heute noch kein
großer wurf ist aber auch nicht zu
erwarten
aber nächste woche ist dann die korrekte
entscheidung er war in der nächsten
woche müssen wir die grundlegenden
weichen stellen wie es weiter zu
verfahren gibt
positiv ist das ist in der tat so dass
die große exponentielle welle gebrochen
ist das ist die positive nachricht
dieser tage aber es reicht noch nicht
die zahlen stagnieren auf hohem niveau
sie beginnen zu stagnieren aber dies
wird nicht reichen um am ende
tatsächlich eine nachhaltige antwort auf
krohn abzugeben dahin zu ziehen muss ja
sein
nicht nur auf dem jetzigen level eine
stagnation zu erreichen sondern die zahl
zu senken
wir müssen eine incidents wert von um
die 50 schaffen warum die 50 das ist
keine fixe idee oder angegriffene zahl
dass es genau der schwellenwert ab dem
es gelingt die nachverfolgung durch die
gesundheitsbehörden dauerhaft zu sichern
und damit infektionsketten auszutrocknen
zu erkennen auszutrocknen und eher
diffuses geschehen zu verhindern das ist
derzeit unser problem das wir
überwiegend gar nicht mehr wissen wo und
durch was wird infiziert und deswegen im
grunde genommen
dieses hohe infektionsgeschehen dar
warum die infektionszahlen sie ist die
mutter aller zahlen aus der
infektionszahlen wachsen alle haben
beide entwickeln daraus krankenhäuser
und was mir viel zu wenig in der
öffentlichen debatte eine rolle spielt
die zahl der todesfälle
ich finde es häufig als eine ethische
kapitulation wenn der eine andere sagt
ja
todesfälle seien normal natürlich gehört
der tod zum leben dazu aber der kampf um
jedes leben die sorge um die sicherheit
der menschen ist eine probe aufgabe eine
schutzfunktion die das öffentliche
gemeinwesen der staat und die wir alle
haben sollen
deswegen ganz klar wir müssen diese
zahlen weiter drücken ganz europa tut es
übrigens sind und seinen nachbarländern
wird sogar mit deutlich heftigeren
maßnahmen reagiert als wir haben habe
ich vor den mildesten lockdown in ganz
europa deswegen ist die maßnahme die
jetzt getroffen waren gut aber ich habe
wenig hoffnung dass ende november alles
wieder gut ist
jetzt muss man ehrlicherweise sagen da
gibt es auch bislang kein anders und zog
alle wenn man alle zahlen sieht und
berechnet gibt es zunächst einmal keinen
anlass zu glauben ab anfang dezember ist
alles wieder wie früher und im zweifel
müssen wir auf sicherheit setzen
das schlechteste wäre ein ständiges auf
und ab vier wochen auf vier warum sie
denn da geht die bevölkerung nicht mit
es wie bei jeder therapie wir müssen sie
versuchen solange durchzuführen damit
wir am ende zum erfolg kommen das heißt
lieber verlängern stadt vorzeitig
abzubrechen
zum thema vertiefen da haben wir heute
schon den ersten appell gemacht aber
nächste woche wenn wir noch mal schauen
ob wir das schaffen können in form von
beschlüssen
neben kontakte weiter zu reduzieren ein
klares wort zu dem thema schulen
das ist meine man auch ein ganz großes
thema ein wichtiges gesellschaftliches
thema übrigens allein deswegen weil ich
finde dass gerade unsere junge leute die
er gern immer so gescholten werden dass
sie zur tat machen in diesen zeiten auch
eine besondere belastung tor
die älteren tragen die herausforderung
der möglichen gesundheitsgefährdungen
aber für die jüngeren sind es schon
enorme einschränkungen meine erfahrung
ist wirklich sagen gerade bei den
schülerinnen schüler dass sie all diese
maßnahme mit großer gelassenheit und
engagement mittragen das sind gilt an
dieser stelle auch unsere fürsorge und
er dankt den schülerinnen und schüler
wenn über schule reden ja wir haben die
priorität dass schule offen bleiben soll
aber insbesondere den hotspots muss man
sagen müssen wir darüber nachdenken ob
das offenlassen auf biegen und brechen
die 1
wirklich mögliche reaktion ist warum
werde ich dort gesehen auch bei uns wo
die inzidenz zahlen sehr hoch sind dass
auch anpassungen in der schule schon
erhebliche erfolge bringen kontakte zu
reduzieren
deswegen muss das nächste woche bis
nächste woche noch einmal genau
anschauen wie wir damit umgehen
ob es für bestimmte bereiche für
bestimmte betroffene gruppen und es sind
vor allem die älteren schüler ob es da
nicht ein angebot geben kann eine
entzerrung im unterricht zu erreichen
wie in bayern haben maske auch in der
grundschule das funktioniert übrigens im
großen ganzen sehr gut warum weil es
eine präventiv möglichkeit ist schule
auch an der stelle offen zu lassen
wir waren uns jetzt in den nächsten
tagen auch alle die länder untereinander
austauschen welche wege wieder an der
stelle gehen können sicherheit für
schulen schüler aber eben auch für die
lehrerinnen lehrer zu erreichen die sind
ja auch besonders betroffen ein punkt
ist mir ganz besonders wichtig es gibt
nicht nur bei der schule darüber offen
oder zu
jetzt geht darum gefragt was in der
schule derzeit sind denn unabhängig von
der fibaa das vielleicht ein anderer der
schülern der schüler lehrer hat steigt
die temperatur in den schulen der
unsicherheiten entstehen und es sind
brauchen die der gemeinschaftlich klare
vorgaben in deutschland mit dem thema
schule umgehen können
die bibel vor allem auch den
leistungsdruck an das andenken
es kann nicht sein dass der eindruck
entsteht vielleicht muss man den
leistungsdruck sogar erhöhen weil die
gefahr besteht dass die schule dann
irgendwann zu ist es wird auch kein
normales schuljahr werden
aber es muss ein fehler sein mit guten
abschlussbedingungen und deswegen muss
auch flexibilität im schulalltag nichtig
seien damit am ende die schülerinnen
schüler keinen jahrgang bekommen an
denen sich nur nicht erinnert nur wegen
koma sondern möglicherweise eine debatte
um die bildungsqualität ist da muss
alles an maximaler flexibilität in der
schulbürokratie stattfinden also dass
wir nächste woche dann gemeinschaftlich
entscheiden und dann stehen da die
bundeskanzlerin zu recht sagte vor der
frage wie planen wir die nächsten wochen
ich weiß nicht ob man eine
planungssicherheit für nächster zeit ist
ja garantieren kann
also wenn man zurückschaut und wir haben
ja schon öfters die konferenz
ein gespräch gehabt zwei wochen vor der
entscheidenden ministerin konferenz wo
man die lockerheit beschlossen haben man
sehr viele kollegen noch der meinung
vielleicht gibt es auch anders wir
müssen uns in corona auch daran gewöhnen
dass es nicht die planungssicherheit
gibt aber unser ziel ist so weit wie
möglich voraus schauen zu können
der impfstoff wird uns schon sehr helfen
unser ziel ist ja wir hatten einmal ein
log daten gehabt und zwischen dem ersten
und dem zweiten lok tor lag fast ein
halbes jahr also nicht jeden monat
insofern gibt es gewisse berechenbarkeit
wir dürfen nur nicht den fehler machen
zu früh und sind sicherheit zu wägen
krone hat jeden bestraft der geglaubt
hat es sei schon vor schnell vorbei
selbst die freunde in österreich die
wirklich sehr gut geantwortet haben
mussten es jetzt leider erkennen andere
länder eben auch deswegen ist uns ganz
wichtig dass wir den dezember und auch
weihnachten noch mal genauer anschauen
ich mache mir ehrlicherweise um
weihnachten das weihnachtsfest weniger
sorge als das was ein semester passieren
könnte weil ich stelle mir vor dass die
normalen weihnachtsfest zu hause dann
mit der familie doch sehr möglich sein
können aber was passiert denn silvester
und das sagen mir verzeihen verziehen
als bayer wenn ich das sage so richtig
vorstellen wollte ich mir nicht das
möglicherweise große schiffe er wenn wir
der stadt finden wir haben das einmal
schon erlebt so dass wir uns das
wirklich sehr genau anschauen müssen wir
haben gerade in den grenzbereichen
besondere herausforderungen
deswegen müssen uns das nächste woche
auch noch einmal genau anschauen oder
auch eine idee entwickeln damit umgehen
letzter oder vorletzter punkte ich teile
die auffassung dass wir bei der bahn
mehr machen können und ich möchte auch
noch überlegen ob wir nicht an beim
datenschutz eine einheitsschule
überprüfung ob es da hindernisse gibt
die diskussion so viel in diesem jahr
über die einschränkung von
bewegungsfreiheit diskutieren ist es ja
so intensiv über grundrechte und der
einzige bereich der für den speziellen
bereich eine hohe sicherheit bringen
könnte nämlich die wanne
die könnte uns mehr bewegungsfreiheit
geben in anderen ländern auch mehr
bewegungsfreiheit für den einzelnen
wenn wir an der stelle bei den
datenschutz noch mal überprüfen ob es
hindernisse gibt die mir vielleicht an
der stelle verbessern können
das wäre noch ein dringender appell also
nicht nur jetzt nur eine neue funktion
freischalten sondern wirklich noch mehr
grundsätzlich überlegen weil die wand
ist eigentlich eine super geschichte und
ich glaube dass ihre wirksamkeit noch
viel besser entfalten könnte und jetzt
der punkt war die meldungen überall
waren angriffe und was mit der weniger
werden
das würde ich so halt nicht so sehen
also natürlich als papst heute
unterschiedliche akzente meinungen und
das hätte man heute auch noch ein
bisschen eleganter machen können im
vorfeld auch die länder untereinander
wenn ich das so sagen darf trotzdem ein
uns alle das bemühen nach bestem wissen
und gewissen haben die schutzfunktion zu
erfüllen und mit den bürgern zusammen
etwas zu erreichen das würde ich nochmal
ausdrücklich sagen weil er die ganzen
zwischenmeldung oder einmal auch die
menschen verunsichern und verwirren das
was wir heute gemacht haben ist genau
der richtige weg wir haben noch nicht
endgültig entschieden
wir warten jetzt noch die nächsten tage
ab die zahlen sind und wenn er klug auch
intensiv beraten wie wir mit denen noch
nicht entschieden in fragen umgehen
werden aber das bewusstsein einheitlich
zu handeln
und da jetzt nicht in irgendeiner streit
agonie zu verfallen bleibt ungebrochen
hoch und es waren wir auch nächste woche
glaube ich so dokumentieren danke
andreas rinke reuters sie haben die
erste frage eine frage die an die
bundeskanzlerin und eigentlich an die
ministerpräsidenten beide geht ich habe
noch nicht richtig verstanden was genau
nächste woche der schwellenwert sein
wird sind das dann diese 50 jahr sollen
sie sich angeschaut und sich versprochen
wenn nächste woche die 50 nicht erreicht
sind wird es verlängerungen von
maßnahmen geben wird weitere
beschränkungen geben oder ab welchem
punkt zehn zusätzliche maßnahmen in der
nächsten woche sicher sein dass wir die
50 erreichen das heißt wir müssen auf
die 50 kommen und das ist unser ziel und
an dem ziel haben wir auch nichts
verändert
wir müssen sie jetzt nicht auf 51 aber
50 ist das ziel
und dann kann man immer sagen na ja es
geht ja noch ein bisschen runter
eigentlich wollen wir euch unter 50
kommen nämlich die 35 sind noch sicherer
aber wir müssen in die nähe der 50
kommen wir sind jetzt seit dem 28
oktober im grunde das wussten wir aber
nochmal angestiegen und sind jetzt oft
auf einem platz hoch und sind so bei 140
100.000 und das muss runter gehen wir
sehen wenn wirklich kontakt
beschränkungen in hohem maße und wir
haben ja damals gesagt ein bisschen 75%
kontakt kontakte weniger sein wenn die
wirklich durchgeführt werden wir haben
jetzt in belgien gesehen und einen
anderen ländern gibt es auch einen
ziemlich steilen abfall ab einem
bestimmten punkt aber wenn das zu wenig
ist damit sollen darüber nachdenken sie
waren mehr kontakte dann auch reduzieren
wieder
fakt ist diese 50er zahl der zimmer
gesehen wenn man nicht deutlich an die
50 gramm kommt oder runter kommt wird es
nach kurzer zeit wieder hochgehen kann
man wirklich wetten gab es genau erlebt
dass wir massenhaft oder flächendeckend
über 50km begann ist dann irgendwann
nach oben zu springen das ist diese zahl
50 eben keine fixe idee sondern finde
eine sehr auch durch wissenschaftler
auch durch die praxis belegte zahl
wenn du zum beispiel ende nächster woche
über 100 werden präsident wird dann hat
es wenig sind einfach zu sagen wir wir
können nichts machen und dann muss man
sich dann noch überlegen was geht lieber
lieber etwas länger dafür nachhaltiger
als schneller und dann müssen wir wieder
von vorne anfangen
mir fällt nur noch mal sagen die 50
haben etwas zu tun mit der struktur
unseres gesundheitswesens und wir haben
uns sehr früh im frühjahr darauf
geeinigt wie die gesundheitsämter
ausgestattet sein sollen und das immer
fünf leute einen kontakt nachvollziehen
und zweiter darauf ist dass aufgebaut
wenn er ein land werden das historisch
gewachsenen zehnmal so große
gesundheitsämter
dann könnte man auch eine etwas höhere
instanz machen aber ich will das noch
mal deutlich machen was auch markus
söder gesagt hat werten im sommer unter
zehn tote am tag wir haben jetzt über
200 an vielen tagen
und wir haben viele menschen bei großen
infektionszahlen natürlich auch die
ziemlich lang anhaltende schädigungen
haben das heißt wenn man mal uns
anschauen wie im asiatischen raum ist
südkorea australien neuseeland geguckt
wird dass man im grunde sozusagen
dreistellige infektionszahlen nicht
überschreitet dann muss man auch sagen
dass rettet jedes mal menschenleben das
ist ganz einfach so weil auch das muss
man mit einbeziehen jörg blank dpa
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben heute
viele attraktive dinge beschlossen im
privatbereich jetzt haben sie in der
pressekonferenz eben mehrfach gesagt
nächste woche wäre das rechtsänderungen
geben betrifft das möglicherweise auch
den privatbereich und können sie sagen
in welchen bereichen denn dieser
rechtsänderung möglicherweise auf die
menschen zukommen
eine frage noch an herrn müller wenn wir
dann nach dem es offensichtlich sehr
viel kritik an dem verfahren des
kanzleramtes gegeben hat mit einer
beschlussvorlage vorzulegen wird es
demnächst an so sein dass sie als
vorsitzender ministerpräsidenten runde
die beschlussvorlage erstellen und dann
in die diskussion eingeben oder erhält
man am bisherigen verfahren fest danke
also wir haben ja heute dadurch dass wir
auch schon noch mal sozusagen auf
forderungen an die bevölkerung gegeben
haben deutlich gemacht dass ein großer
bereich die kontakte sind und dann
sollen es noch mehr gesehen wir sind aus
dem exponentiellen wachstum rausgekommen
durch das schließen und bestimmter
einrichtungen
im freizeitbereich und natürlich muss
sondern auch darüber sprechen kann man
das zum ersten mal das wieder öffnen
oder nicht und wenn wir noch zu weit
entfernt sind müssen wir da auch die
entsprechenden maßnahmen machen und dann
ist eben auch der bereich schule der wo
es nicht um eine schließung geht um das
mal ganz klar zu sagen weder im
kita-bereich noch im grundschulbereich
noch bei den höheren schutz last ist ein
bereich wo man überlegen muss wie kann
ich deutlich jene bestimmungen sehr gut
einheiten denn wir haben zwölf millionen
schülerinnen und schüler in deutschland
und eine millionen lehrer das sind sehr
viele kontakte die da sind aber jeder
einzelne bürger kann durch das vermeiden
von zusätzlichen kontakten etwas
erreichen und wo immer das möglich ist
wird das auch rechtlich festgeschrieben
zu ihrer zweiten frage wir hatten ja in
der vergangenheit sehr gut funktionieren
und geübte verfahren das für gemeinsame
sitzungen gemeinsame papiere auch
gemeinsam erarbeitet werden und wir
haben uns heute darauf verständigt dass
wir daher auch wieder hin wollen dass
wir nun zu diesem verfahren zurückkehren
das kanzleramt hat er jetzt doch sehr
kurzfristig mitunter papiere auch
erarbeitet dafür gibt es auch
unterschiedliche und objektive gründe
durchsage das völlig ohne jeden vorwurf
aber wir müssen bisher zwischen 16
ländern auch noch beraten können und das
dann entscheiden am sonntagabend um 23
uhr machen zu müssen und montagfrüh geht
es dann gleich weiter dient oft auch der
sache nicht und insofern wollen wir das
jetzt auch für die kommende woche besser
vorbereiten richtig ist wir werden die
länder seit ich das schon mal intern
abstimmen werden es zwischen den a und b
ländern auch abstimmen und werden dann
mit sicherheit auch früher einen entwurf
eines papiers und einer positionierung
haben dass wir dann natürlich auch
gemeinsam noch einmal durchgehen werden
gemeinsam dann weiter entwickeln werden
und gemeinsam beschließen wollen das
soll überhaupt keine konfrontation sein
sondern soll einfach auch für beide
seiten für bund und länder ein verfahren
ermöglichen mit denen man sich mit dem
man sich dann doch intensiver und besser
mit den fragen auseinandersetzen kann
als es jetzt in den letzten zwei drei
sitzungen der fall war
doch ich sage doch gerade wir werden ein
vorspiel werden etwas erarbeiten wir
werden einen vorschlag machen aber wir
wollen dann den beschlussvorschlag auch
natürlich miteinander abstimmen und
werden dann in der sitzung gehen auch
beraten und ich bin ganz sicher es wird
eine nein so weit gehen zu und gut
abgestimmter beschluss sein dass wir da
auch sehr konstruktiv dann in der
konkreten sitzung damit umgehen können
und auch zu einer guten gemeinsamen
beschlussfassung kommen für das ganz
offen sagen wir haben jetzt gleich mal
so das gefühl gehabt und das ist ja auch
die rezeption dass der bund und auch ich
persönlich sehr drängen auf bestimmte
maßnahmen und dann sozusagen ein
bisschen vielleicht die länder gar nicht
so euphorisch folgen
und jetzt haben einfach mal gesagt wir
wollen noch mal wissen was die länder
denken aber soll natürlich münden ein
gemeinsames papier von bund und ländern
ist ja ganz klar besser klingen sie
wieder so ein papier aber da guck mal
was wollen die länder dass der bund wird
sich natürlich auch gedanken machen und
dann legt man das mal zusammen aber
sozusagen wir tragen ja wie markus söder
gesagt hat alle die gemeinsame
verantwortung das ist ja nicht so dass
der eine hier die lasten verteilt unter
anderem das vergnügen sondern dass
dieses diese faire lastenteilung wollen
wir noch mal etwas besser ausprobieren
wir werden sehen ob das besser nein
verwirrt ich bin da noch nicht ganz
sicher
kristina dunz für die rheinische post
hat das muss ich einmal frau
bundeskanzlerin sie hatten mitte oktober
von unheil gesprochen als sich in der
runde mit dem ministerpräsidenten nicht
der fortschritt erzielen ließ den sie
sich vorstellten
würden sie heute dann von einer
zeitverschwendung von einer woche
ausgehen weil ihn ja viele dinge
drängender erscheinen und herr söder
sie haben gesagt das war heute nicht der
große wurf der kommt dann liest aber
auch nächste woche wenn man heute schon
weiß dass nächste woche der große wurf
kommt warum macht man das nicht schon
heute und das stellen sie sich genau vor
was dieser große wurf ist
also der der punkt ist dass wir heute
alle miteinander
das will ich ganz deutlich sagen nicht
wissen ob das jetzt schlagartig weiter
geht es auf das und da geht das kann ich
nicht genau ermessen ich kann nur sagen
es gibt immer noch an manchen stellen
ganz schön viel kontakte aber es hat
sich auch deutlich was verringert und
jetzt müssen wir halt sehen wie sich das
entwickeln deshalb kann man auch heute
noch nicht mit letzter sicherheit also
man kann es nicht nur noch weniger als
letzter sicherheit man kann heute nicht
sagen was ist nächste woche gewählten
das muss ich ganz offen sagen richtig
ist trotzdem wenn man heute noch mal im
privaten bereich die kontakte rechtlich
verbindlich verändert hätte dann hätte
man wieder sieben tage gehabt oder sechs
die in denen das schon gewirkt hätte auf
der anderen seite gibt es aber auch
argumente zu sagen wenn wir jetzt schon
wissen dass wir nächste woche wieder was
andere wiederum rechts paket auflegen
dann wollen wir um der besseren
verständlichkeit will das dann erst
gemeinsam nächste woche machen
je eher je besser und wir haben uns
gesehen wenn man jetzt sich das einfach
anschaut
ich sag nur österreich hat jetzt sehr
harte maßnahmen ergriffen die haben
einen einen eine instanz von im
durchschnitt über 500 da sind wir mit
unseren 140 immer noch sommer auf einer
überschaubaren seite belgien lag ähnlich
hoch niederlande
die haben alle einen sehr langen weg
dann zu gehen und so ist es bei uns auch
wenn man sozusagen die ersten anzeichen
des exponentiellen wachstums sieht weiß
man eigentlich wenn man jenseits der
fünfzig ist an zu vielen stellen dass
man es nicht mehr gestoppt kriegt und je
früher man handelt umso besser ich
glaube mit unserem beschlussfassung
jetzt dass wir das nächste woche dann
nochmal im gesamtüberblick bewerten ist
es gut und die mahnungen die wir heute
aussprechen die sind einheitlich und
gemeinsam und wirklich ernst und das
habe ich extra heute nochmal so
vorgelesen wie es auch von uns gemeint
ist ein
festen anderen haus stand und das gilt
auch für familien mit kindern um nicht
so sagen die vermischung das
infektionsgeschehen es immer weiter zu
tragen
es ist schon gesagt von bergemann texte
muss man dann entscheiden wird es
verlängert wird es aufgehoben wird es
vielleicht verschafft also deswegen die
entscheidung im nächsten jahr
stattfindet ubs nicht punkt und wir
haben
sagen wir mal so das reicht dann nächste
woche aber man hat natürlich das
einander heute kontakt beschränkung das
wort geredet haben hätte man schon
machen können aber im prinzip müssen wir
nächste woche dann eine entlang zeugs
der geräte vorstellen wie es geht und
ich hoffe dass wir dazu die kraft finden
das ganze zu machen dennis hat corona
erfordert von uns hat einfach auch woche
für woche von am ende auf dem boutique
entscheidung verstärken darf es geht
wirklich auch um die frage wie wir
langfristig eine perspektive und ein
konzept erarbeiten können sie können
jede einzelne maßnahme jeden tag neu
beschließen
aber wir sind an einem punkt glaube ich
auch wo man einerseits konkret auf die
zahlen reagieren muss und wo man auf der
anderen seite auch jetzt für die
wintermonate nicht nur den bürgerinnen
und bürgern sondern auch institutionen
häuser an der kultur der gastronomie
einmal eine perspektive vermitteln muss
wo es hingehen kann und ich sage kann
weil wir in einer lage eben sind wo man
auch gegebenenfalls noch mal
zwischendurch eingreifen muss wenn sich
dinge nicht so entwickeln wie man sie
erwartet aber wir wollen uns damit
auseinandersetzen wie es die nächsten
wochen oder monate aussehen kann nicht
ein halbes jahr alt also da völlig recht
als er das gesagt hat da in der
situation sind wir wahrscheinlich nicht
dass wir das für ein halbes jahr
formulieren können aber doch für einen
längeren zeitraum als von woche zu woche
und diese zeit wollen wir uns nehmen
dafür kann man anschließend an die frage
von eben dafür wollen wir uns auch die
zeit der vorbereitung nehmen und
entsprechend gut vorbereitet sein so
dass man auch mal das themenspektrum
sich konkret an guckt nicht nur die
kontakte im privaten bereich sondern
noch mal was es in den theatern
ökonomie in den schulen da haben sie ein
großes themenspektrum und zum schluss
muss einst auch ins andere greifen eine
sache sich herauszugreifen mag
gegebenenfalls auch schon ein erfolg
bringen aber mit sicherheit nicht so
dauerhaft wie ein in sich schlüssiges
konzept aus zeitgründen müssen wir es
leider bei diesen fragen bewenden lassen
ich bitte um verständnis ich schön haben
okay danke schön
tja so weit also die pressekonferenz von
bund und ländern in berlin die ungefähr
vier stunden später begonnen hat als wir
uns das eigentlich gedacht hatten denn
es hat länger gedauert bevor wir das
kurz zusammenfassen
baic in twins schreibt über youtube also
wurde nichts neues entschieden
fragezeichen
und genauso kann man das eigentlich
zusammen fassen
es wurde darüber gesprochen dass es
nächsten mittwoch einen neues treffen
geben wird und wie markus söder das
formuliert hat heute wohl gemahnt
nächste woche soll entschieden werden es
geht darum die kontakte weiter zu
vermeiden
dazu wurde heute gesagt die schulen
sollen erstmal weiter offen bleiben aber
es gibt den dringenden appell an die
bevölkerung zum einen auf private feiern
gänzlich zu verzichten
auf private zusammenkünfte mit freunden
und verwandten und bekannten sich nur zu
beschränken auf einen weiteren hausstand
freizeit bezogene aktivitäten in
bereichen mit publikumsverkehr und nicht
notwendige private reisen auch darauf
sollte man verzichten nicht notwendige
aufenthalte in geschlossenen räumen mit
publikumsverkehr sollte man vermeiden
und auch besuche bei besonders
verletzlichen personen sollte man nur
absolvieren wenn man symptomfrei ist das
allerdings hat alles nur in
anführungszeichen appellcharakter das
sind noch keine verbote oder gebote
sondern der die dringende mahnung an die
bevölkerung sich an diese regeln zu
halten
außerdem wurde beschlossen dass sfp zwei
masken geben soll für ältere menschen
und menschen die besonders gefährdet
sind mit einer geringen eigen
einigung wir wollen darüber heute abend
sprechen wir freuen uns über eure und
ihre fragen und kommentare wie immer in
die kommentare
und wenn ihr die zdf- heute- app nutzt
dann bitte an diese adresse ich glaube
man kann sie nicht sehen ich weiß nicht
auswendig aber ich hoffe ihr kennt sie
alle und findet sie raus und da ist ja
auch schon so wunderbar haben wir das
auch ich bin nicht alleine heute abend
sondern ich freue mich sehr dass bei mir
im studio ist der virologe dr martin
stürmer aus frankfurt der selbst dort
ein labor leitet und dozent ist am
institut für medizinische virologie an
der uni frankfurt und in berlin sehen
wir richtet sich gerade noch einen
nicole diekmann unsere korrespondentin
vor ort die diesen langen nachmittag bis
in den abend hinein für uns verfolgt hat
nicole ein satz der auch die politischen
differenzen oder die differenzen der
entscheidungsträger ganz gut darstellt
von angela merkel ist mir in erinnerung
geblieben der fiel ziemlich am anfang
es gab ein bisschen unterschiedliche
vorstellungen darüber was denn heute bei
diesem treffen beschlossen werden soll
wie bewertest du das was du heute im
kanzleramt statt gefunden hat
ich höre dass wir nicole diekmann leider
nur sehen aber nicht hören und hofft
jetzt a sehr gut ich weiß nie wann
fehler entschuldigung
die new taste viele leute die im hobby
sind kennen die erkennen die new taste
genau nicole bitte noch mal von vorn ich
sag es gleich vorweg das ist nichts was
einem im november noch passieren sollte
aber so ist es mir passiert
also ich sage es nochmal was heute
eigentlich beschlossen worden ist ist
dass man noch woche zeit hat um sich
seelisch darauf vorzubereiten dass die
maßnahme verlängert werden es war ja von
dezember und januar die rede da steht im
übrigen auch in dem beschluss der jetzt
vorliegt und zweitens ich glaube darauf
müssen wir uns alle einstellen dass die
maßnahmen auch verschärft werden
markus söder hat soeben gesagt heute
mahnen wir nur und was heute ja ein
zentraler punkt war der appell im moment
noch ist eben die beschränkung der
kontakte in der freizeit wenn wir das
jetzt also konsequent zu ende denken
wird das nächste woche nicht mehr nur
appellativen charakter haben sondern
soll in beschlüsse gegossen werden jetzt
ist nur die frage wer soll sich seelisch
noch eine woche darauf vorbereitet für
wen hat man jetzt diese ich sag's mal
wartezeit noch eingerichtet
entweder sind es die
ministerpräsidentinnen die sich dazu
heute noch nicht durchringen konnten
oder aber man meint dass die zustimmung
innerhalb der bevölkerung größer ist
wenn man noch eine woche eben die zeit
muss sich mental vorzubereiten denn was
ich ganz interessant fand eben war dass
angela merkel zweimal das wort
berechenbarkeit benutzt hat und auch
markus söder hat das später noch mal
verwendet das ist eigentlich ein
paradoxon man hat ende oktober als die
jetzt geltenden beschlüsse gefasst
wurden gesagt das gilt für den november
was wir heute gehört haben ist ja dass
das nicht stimmt es wird noch über den
november hinaus gehen und dass man sich
da selber widersprochen hat bzw dass man
da jetzt wortbrüchig werden muss das
begründet man mit berechenbarkeit wenn
man da länger darüber nachdenkt ist das
schon schlüssig weil man nämlich
sagt wenn wir jetzt sagen im dezember
gehen wir zurück zum zum status quo ante
dann müssen wir im januar spätestens
wieder nachschärfen trotz alledem wird
es interessant sein zu sehen ob die
leute das den politiker innen übel
nehmen dass jetzt also ganz klar ist es
wird im dezember und im januar
weitergehende beschränkungen
nun ist die frage stichwort
berechenbarkeit
du hast schon sehr viele dieser corona
pks begleitet und auch erlebt was dann
in den tagen danach passiert ist dass
beschlüsse dann wieder zerpflückt oder
individuell sehr unterschiedlich
ausgelegt wurden auf diese
berechenbarkeit warten ja die menschen
quasi seit beginn der pandemie und haben
oft erlebt dass sie nach diesen
sitzungen im kanzleramt überhaupt nicht
mehr wussten woran sie sind
was glaubst du wie klar werden diese
regeln tatsächlich werden also hier
schreibt zum beispiel florian nix über
youtube wird familien weihnachtsfeiern
okay also mit ein paar verwandten also
da kann ich kann ich mit meiner familie
weihnachten feiern das sind ja die
fragen die sich die leute dann stellen
wird die politik hier darauf klare
antworten geben können
das wird sie sicherlich tun denn neben
den großen leitsatz schulen offen lassen
ist ja das zweite große schlagwort in
den letzten wochen immer gewesen
weihnachten
man will ja das weihnachtsfest retten
was das bedeutet definitiv das wird man
in einer woche sehen jetzt haben die
ministerpräsidentin eine woche lang zeit
sich darüber gedanken zu machen das
risiko dass er drin liegt ist auch dass
man jetzt eine woche lang zeit hat sich
darüber zu zerfleischen das was vorher
immer passiert ist nach terminen wie
heute wenn da klare beschlüsse gefasst
worden sind das bisher heute nicht
passiert das ist ja rechtlich nicht
bindend was da heute beschlossen worden
ist oder besprochen worden ist sagen wir
es mal so
aber das leitet natürlich alle das
weihnachtsfest zu retten jetzt aber
nicht nur sage ich mal weil man
weihnachten so wichtig findet aus
emotionalen gründen sondern ersten bei
max versprochen hat und zweitens weil
ich glaube dass die enttäuschung in der
bevölkerung riesengroß wird wenn einem
auch noch ich sag's mal total salopp das
weihnachtsfest wird und noch mal wir
sind ja alle
wähler und wählerinnen und nächstes jahr
wird gewählt also man will sich darauf
natürlich auch festnageln lassen und hat
das ja schon vor einigen wochen selbst
als ziel definiert doch dahinter kommt
man nicht zurück die frage an den
virologen wenn sie das aus politischer
korrespondenten sich die einschätzung
hören was ist ihre meinung ist das der
richtige schritt versuchen da die waage
zu halten oder würden sie sich als
virologe wünschen wir machen es wie die
österreicher wir machen alles zu wohl
wissend dass man dann diesen jojo effekt
hat und sagt okay wir machen alles zu
dann macht mal wieder alles auf und so
weiter also mir ist ja freiwilligkeit
und und eigenverantwortung ein ganz ganz
wichtiger bestandteil der gesamten
diskussion und insofern würde ich das
natürlich bevorzugen wenn wir das auf
diesem wege schaffen
das problem was nicht so ein bisschen
sehe ist das ja die appelle an die
freiwilligkeit und die
eigenverantwortung nicht erst seit
gestern haben die bevölkerung richten
sondern das ist eigentlich schon der
grundtenor auch als das mit der mit den
steigenden zahlen losgehen wie oft haben
wir gewarnt
als wir gesehen haben es kommen viele
infektionen aus privaten feier bereich
da haben auch die die warnungen der
wurde ja versucht auch schon mit
vorgaben im privaten bereich
einzugreifen
man hat gesehen das geht gar nicht weil
wir der rechtlichen möglichkeiten haben
dort zu stark einzuschränken und
insofern ist das jetzt einfach eine
wiederholung eines appells den auch frau
merkel schon mehrfach an die bevölkerung
gerichtet hat mag sein dass das wording
ein anderes ist ich weiß nicht ob damit
wirklich weiterkommen
meine hoffnung war es und ist es
eigentlich auch immer noch ich habe ein
bisschen zweifelt dann blicken wir mal
gemeinsam auf einen komplex der die
userinnen und user sehr bewegt nämlich
die frage nach dem thema schule
die sollen erstmal offen bleiben haben
wir gerade gehört stand heute was dann
nächste woche entschieden wird das steht
in den sternen
die kanzlerin hat sich dazu geäußert
wir haben uns geäußert zu der frage von
schulen und betreuungseinrichtungen wir
danken erst einmal all denen die unseren
politischen grundsatz wir wollen schulen
kitas aufhalten wir wollen dass schule
und kindergarten und kita stattfindet
die diesem grundsatz auch das
funktionieren geben also alle die im
schulwesen arbeiten den
kindergärtnerinnen kindergärten danken
wir für alles was sie leisten und wir
wissen auch dass die länder sich täglich
mit dem funktionieren von kitas
kindergärten und schulen beschäftigen
tja auch im netz beschäftigen sich viele
mit dieser frage ich fasse mir gerade
zusammen mario pedro schreibt auf
youtube kontakt beschränkungen daheim
reduzieren aber in der schule locker mit
zehn verschiedenen haushalten treffen
super auch über youtube schreibt amazon
regenwald ich liebe diese user namen
also auf jeden fall schreibt er
das virus ist erst nachmittags aktiv
also natürlich die ironische frage
danach macht es morgens in der schule
pause und nachmittags ist dann denkt wie
alles eh schon wurscht
dann schreibt auch jemand über youtube
kinder sind dennoch überträger wieso
wird das derart heruntergeredet noch mal
die frage an den virologen wie bewerten
sie das infektionsgeschehen an schulen
ja man darf es nicht außer acht lassen
also die die kommentare sind ja absolut
berechtigt ich mein das virus kennt
keine sperrstunde ist kennt nehmen
entsprechend auch keine frühstückspause
und wir wissen dass kinder ansteckend
sind wir wissen dass kinder sich selbst
infizieren können wir haben sie auch
gehört dass das milde verläufe sind aber
das rechtfertigt noch lange nicht zu
argumentieren dass das ganze
dementsprechend zu verharmlosen ist also
man muss sich ganz klar gedanken machen
wie man die schulen sicherer bekommt
damit wir eben nicht weiteres
ausbruchsgeschehen haben es war ja davon
die rede dass sind deutschland sehr
wenig schulen verhältnis geschlossen
sind
ich werde mir aber die schülerzahlen an
gucken die sich in quarantäne befinden
wir wollen wir uns nicht mehr im
promillebereich und ich glaube das ist
einfach ein signal das sollten wir sehr
sehr ernst nehmen und möglichst schnell
strategien entwickeln um eben auch genau
der der kritik zu recht gerecht werden
nämlich mechanismen wie wir eben die
klassen
größen reduzieren wie wir einfach die
infektionsgefahr in den schulen deutlich
minimieren sei es durch masken durch
filteranlagen und da gibt es viele ideen
die müssen jetzt relativ schnell
umgesetzt werden
das sind alles sachen die nicole in der
allerersten beschlussvorlage zum teil
auch schon drin standen die wir gestern
abend aus dem bundeskanzleramt bekommen
haben ich muss mal aus all den entwürfen
die hier liegen den richtigen rat suchen
es ist nicht so einfach heute aber da
stand zum beispiel ein verpflichtendes
tragen eines mund nasenschutz es für
schülerinnen und schüler aller jahrgänge
die die gruppen sollen gebildet werden
klassenräume sollen die gruppen in den
klassenräumen sollen halbiert werden im
vergleich zum regelbetrieb sind das
alles sachen die wir dann nächste woche
am kommenden mittwoch am 25 wenn sie
sich alle wieder treffen werden
möglicherweise wieder hören und dann
aber auch als beschluss wieder sehen
werden
also ich sags mal so wenn das so sein
sollte war das wirklich eine verschenkte
woche wenn man markus söder gerade
gehört hat dann ist das so aber es wird
ja einen grund haben warum davon nichts
mehr in den beschluss der uns jetzt
vorliegt zu lesen ist das einzige was
man dazu zum thema schulen jetzt findet
ist noch mal der satz bund und länder
werden auf der nächsten konferenz
darüber beraten
die ansteckungsrisiken im schulbereich
in hotspots reduziert werden können wäre
man heute zu der annahme gelangt das
würde sich wirklich dadurch so gestalten
oder dann würde zu diesem ziel gelangen
indem man eben diese maßnahmen die du
gerade auch schon angesprochen hast
ergreifen also ab der ersten klasse
durchgehend auch im unterricht
maskengruppen bilden die dauerhaft
getrennt voneinander unterrichtet werden
dann hätte man das heute ja schon
beschließen können ich bin sehr gespannt
was der nächste woche beschlossen wird
so dass da alle gesicht waren das ja
immer eine wichtige kategorie in der
politik raufgehen nicole noch eine
letzte einschätzen de frage an dich
kannst du dir vorstellen dass man auch
ein bisschen darauf spekuliert dass der
effekt einsetzt der im frühjahr vor dem
lockdown eingesetzt hat nämlich dass die
leute ihr leben runtergefahren haben
bevor es überhaupt
quasi verordnet wurde das leben
runterzufahren
also hofft man diese woche jetzt auch
schon zu gewinnen dadurch dass die leute
einfach vorausschauend schon eher ihre
kontakte reduzieren obwohl es so wie es
dann vielleicht ist noch nicht
beschlossen ist oder ist das fünf mal um
die ecke gedacht
natürlich hofft man dass es vergeht ja
auch mittlerweile keine pressekonferenz
mehr in der nicht und zwar auch sehr
sehr zu beginn schon den leuten bedanken
die sich an die regeln halten aber es
würde ja heute auch noch mal ganz klar
gesagt es geht jetzt um den inzidenz
wert von 50 incidents wert wir erinnern
uns 50 neuinfektionen auf 100000
einwohner innen binnen einer woche von
dem sind wir im moment sehr sehr weit
entfernt also ja man hofft darauf dass
die leute von sich aus auch nochmal
dieses signal dass da heute ausgesendet
werden hören aber also die hoffnung
darauf dass der nächste woche erreicht
ist die ist bei 0 nach dieser
pressekonferenz ich widersprechen wir
jetzt selbst eine aller aller
allerletzte frage hätte ich dazu in
lindau an dich die fragt peter peter und
das finde ich interessant weil du das
als journalistin natürlich super
beantworten kannst jetzt ist weg wo sie
jetzt hier im moment moment moment ich
habe es gleich ich habe es gleich und
ich jetzt eine pause taste hätte das gut
so hier peter peter fragt auf youtube
wie finden sie das dass es vier stunden
lang gedauert hat und sich nichts
nützliches überlegt wurde politik kann
manchmal sehr langwierig sein
also ich persönlich finde das natürlich
nun sehen wie gut ich finde diese vier
stunden spaß beiseite das finde ich das
finde ich nicht so nicht so furchtbar
also anscheinend hat man sich da
tatsächlich auch mühe gegeben und hart
miteinander gerungen schwieriger finde
ich diese woche schwieriger finde ich
die woche oder sind ja fast zehn tage
die zwischen dem heutigen termin liegen
und der kommenden woche mittwoch wenn
man sich das nächste mal virtuell
zusammen schalten will das finde ich im
moment schwierig nachzuvollziehen
vielen dank nicole diekmann
für deine und ihre bewertung und dann
sage ich mal munter soweit man das in
diesen zeiten sagen kann kann man ja
eigentlich nicht aber bis nächste woche
vielen dank nicole nach berlin und der
stürmer auch an sie noch eine frage aus
dem chat die ich gerne noch mit ihnen
besprechen möchte weil die auch immer
wieder kommt und die wird nächste woche
auch wieder kommen die zahl nach den 50
infizierten pro 100.000 einwohner
hier schreibt lukas huber auf youtube
die zahl von 50 infizierten infizierten
pro 100000 einwohner ist sehr wohl aus
der luft gegriffen sie hat keinen
wissenschaftlichen hintergrund es ist
eine politische zahl wie schätzen sie
diese werte ein mit denen da operiert
wird im moment ja sind sowohl diese 50
als auch die andere genannte zahl 35
sind letztendlich werte bei denen man im
prinzip inzwischen die erfahrung hat wo
man weiß bis dahin kann man
infektionsgeschehen aktuell
kontrollieren und ab welchem wert
verliert man die kontrolle über das
infektionsgeschehen sie sind insofern
empirische zahlen die sich
herausgebildet haben als nützliche
indikatoren wo wir ein kontrollverlust
befürchten müssen und ja ich sehe auch
die situation im augenblick um das mal
in relation zu setzen wir sind im
augenblick von dieser 50 in einigen
regionen sehr sehr weit entfernt und ich
denke auch nicht dass wir in den
nächsten zehn tagen dort wirklich
deutschlandweit komplett runter kommen
ich glaube aber auch dass man hier jetzt
im aktuell auf zeit spielt und noch mal
mit einer letzten mahnung ich habe
vorhin mal für mich selber formuliert
eine gelbe karte sozusagen zeigt nochmal
an alle bevor man mit der roten karte
eben das spiel deutlich anders
aufstellen wird noch mal versucht eine
dynamik reinzubringen und die zahlen
deutlich nach unten zu bringen
aber ich teile die zweifel dass wir
wahrscheinlich in zehn tagen nicht
wirklich dort sind es wäre uns zu
wünschen uns allen dass uns dann
wirklich verschärfung der maßnahmen
wirklich weg bleiben dass sie dass wir
davon verschont bleiben weil das wäre ja
die konsequenz immer doch das ziel
erreichen würden aber da bedarf es einer
enormen anstrengung in allen bereichen
und ob wir das wirklich schaffen dass
man eingestellt
vielen dank für diese einschätzungen
dank das danke dass sie hier waren und
ich möchte gerne enden
mit einer frage von lisa es die fragt
auf youtube wann nächste woche findet
die neue besprechung statt der 25
november das ist der kommende mittwoch
also nicht der kommune sondern mittwoch
in einer woche um 13 uhr begannen diese
besprechung bislang nicht mutmaßen mal
dass es auch nächste woche so sein wird
und wenn es dann beschlüsse gibt dann
spätestens sehen wir uns oder die
kollegen uns hier wieder bis dahin und
inzwischen bleiben sie uns gewogen und
haben sie noch einen schönen abend